hi this is a science hangout from
science mission
I'm Sadashiva PI so today we have dr.
Nichols Peppino's with us he is the
associate professor in Brown University
he has published several articles in
very respected journals he's in the
editorial board of several journals also
and he has received several grants and
he is one of the emerging scientists in
the field so without much further ado
let's welcome Monaco's Kapinos
hi dr. Peppino's hi hi thank you for
having welcome to science hangout nice
having you over so let's get going can
you please talk about yourself tell
about yourself like how did it all start
from the beginning yes I originally from
grace so I studied medicine in Greece in
Greece we don't have a combined MD ph.d
program when I finish my med studies I
always wanted to do research so in order
to do that I started the PhD after
finishing my MD so and I really loved it
and I decided to follow this career the
basic science career so I have an MD I
don't I never you know practiced
medicine so I don't see patients so my
PhD I did my PhD in Greece as well and
it was a little bit different from what
I'm doing now it was molecular
immunology then after I finished my PhD
I always was fascinated by the nervous
system and I wanted to study the nervous
system so after finishing my PhD I
joined Rockefeller University for a
postdoc and later on the last year as a
junior faculty there
after Rockefeller I left and started my
own lab at Geisinger clinic in
Pennsylvania uh-huh
a year ago I joined Brown University as
associate professor here okay so you
have a pretty interesting cat career and
tell us about some of the people who
encountered who helped you who mentored
you who served you as a role models yes
so one person that influenced but shalt
me when I started my PhD was my PhD
supervisor so see his hair name is Marie
upon her honesty just actually she was
just coming back to Greece from
Rockefeller University of C helped me
because you know from medical school I
didn't have any experience with basic
science she helped me a lot so she did
taught me a lot of the techniques that I
used and also introduced me to
Rockefeller saying that you have to
check this place and buy good after when
I want to Rockefeller it's all I cannot
really say you know I have there one
person as a mentor what what actually
you know dictated my my career so far is
the atmosphere and intellect at
Rockefeller which is an incredible place
and just for just you know having going
to the Faculty Club and having it being
a breakfast or a lunch at the cafeteria
and all around you is like all kinds of
Nobel laureates and last get a world
witnessed and academy of science people
I mean you look up to it and says okay
that's I want to be one of these people
I want to my science to be this good
Rockefeller you know they have them has
an institution I love this is what they
do is they don't want you to to to
enclose yourself so they still you can
you think outside the box think push the
boundaries of distance this is this is
beautiful I mean this is I think what
you should do when you do research and
also you
have fun if you don't have fun then it
doesn't really make sense okay that's
good and I know you are busy with your
research doing a lot of for publishing
and all in addition to research what are
the other extracurricular things you do
like what are your hobbies and my family
I have two kids then my wife we spend
time together we like to travel and I
mean personally I like to play
basketball with some friends I'd like to
say this is basically what I do okay and
coming back to the lab like just tell us
about your lab like people - student
postdocs and so my love now in as I said
we joined a year ago here at Brown so
now I have two postdocs in the lab one
one technician and two graduate students
that's basically my lab right now okay
and how do you motivate these kids
around I think that again my face is
like this so I don't think that I'm
actually not I don't think I don't
believe that you need to motivate people
to do science I think people should be
motivated to be scientists science
should motivate them and then the
projects and what they do every day
should be the highest motivation so what
I mean by that is that they have to be
wake up every day and be very happy to
come to the lab and keep on pushing and
keep on doing science if they don't then
probably it's not the right thing to do
that's my that's how I see things
in the lab we are very we are very
friendly
very we have a very nice village to see
both of us together
so the lab is it works like my office is
always open so they we become in and out
all the time every day we go for lunch
dinner together
so we have a very nice relationship okay
so let's talk about some of the projects
that you are doing and your work yes
so the the work I started again when
when study from from Rockefeller will
give you just a small background of my
work so I worked at peripheral
neuropathies and we used a very
interesting model at Rockefeller so we
used the live leprosy bacteria to infect
the peripheral nerve and because the
leprosy bacteria is about the only
bacterium that actually come infects one
cells and can leave inside this one
cells and it doesn't kill the cell it
just takes over the the both a
transcriptional machinery well so
signaling of this one cell in order to
make a very nice home for the bacteria
but this this process changes this one
cell which what this means this runs and
demyelination this one cell expresses
different proteins that the normal cell
so we thought that we can use this as a
model to understand signaling pathways
that regulate myelination so after I
studied my own lab I'm not working with
bacteria anymore so we continue to work
on on different signaling pathways that
we I study identifying at the
Rockefeller and at some point especially
one particular pathway which we found it
was very interesting that regulates
migration of run cells so we had the
idea now six years ago to to see if this
same pathway regulates migration in of
glioblastoma cells because we know that
in the brain and a dumb brain these are
the cells that actually migrate
expensive so and this is where my
medical background health so I did start
to neurosurgery department at Geisinger
clinic and managed to get through there
through the our collaboration I got an
appointment as a as a director of the
neurosurgery research there so we
established a program for do bla
summaries so which is based on primary
cells so we isolate
we made that a repository of glioma stem
cells and differentiated cells from
patients and we started asking very
basic questions about to understand
migration invasion of these cells also
understand the scriptural responses so
what I'm gonna show today the epigenetic
regulation of peripheral nerve injury
and especially RNA epigenetic
epigenetics with some really interesting
so we translated this to the brain
cancer as well so we're having a big
project without any epigenetics of human
cancer stem cells and as we as we came
to brown I mean we keep having this both
arms of the projects the peripheral
nerve and special in every generation
and the epigenetic stuff and then the do
mass stem cell and do blastoma research
so this is what we basically do in and
that's okay can you please go ahead and
present your work yes of course okay so
my work that we present today is is
actually there all of the nature to
longer distance RNA nerve into the
response and and in order to give you a
background of what is and what how do we
we started working on long non-coding
RNAs nerve injury so what is a nerve
injury response the peripheral nerve so
we know that them that the
differentiation of Schwann cells during
development is regulated by expression
of specific transcription factors
so basically immature on cells during
develop and the receive action on
signals one of the major signals in
Wrigleyville
and this up regulates transfer is
various transcription factors some of
them is like ninnescah a beta of six
billion to and others and which stands
immature on cells to the pro myelinating
states and to to change them from from
eliminating to myelinating the most
important transcription factor that
regulates this transition is easier to
[ __ ] 20 now upon injury there is a
rapid up regulation of c-jun and shocks
to transcription factors and our
regulation of each year - and in a nice
somatic that was published from mr.
Jensen's lab I mean you see that they
mature on cells this is transcription
factors that regulate the transition to
pro myelinating cell and from there on
crops - indeed year - and c-jun of the
main players that regulate myelination
or nerve injury respond in influences so
we know now from from studies of many
many groups in the field that after Ned
come in during nerve injury and after
injuries there are several things that
are happening in the nerve and influenza
so if you want like an overview of these
things is a you you need to suppress
Milan differentiation because what
happens immediately after injury there
is a program that starts which makes one
cells to differentiate it to an immature
state which is and from this cell type
which is called a repair so an cell
which will drive in every generation so
the first thing you have is a dumb
regulation of myelin genes and up
regulation of markers of maturity on
cells then you activate trophic factors
surface proteins which provide support
for injured neurons and the Schwann
cells the regenerating cells from these
regeneration tracks which is called Bank
neurons and where we think this bands
the newly formed to the new action is
going to go and start triggering okay
and so during this injury again again
work for many years and from many labs
so that there are several steps to the
injury response so we have the tropics
of port decrease during the axonal
injury
retrograde retrograde axonal discharge
and local include injury signals that
are generated in the action in the
Swanson's pericardial we have activation
of several signaling pathways people
have sonar con tools and if FDA 3-kinase
mTOR pathway and these signaling
pathways lead to activation or inhibit
transcription factor program as I said
before c-jun easier to see EBP stat3 and
eventually other adhesion guidance
molecules neuropeptides with the
scheduled adapters regulated to form
this to actually regulate this whole
process of regeneration now with it in
this whole process the most important
step is the step where which controls
the transition between the myelinating
Swanson's to dinner very transitory pair
sponsor and we know that this transition
is controlled by a balance of positive
regulators with this year two of six
substan being to NF Kappa beta which
favored the mating state and negative
regulators of myelination like c-jun not
Sox two pax 392 which which actually
favored the repair cell in the Athena
rated state so again the process is not
happening obviously in a day but there
is a time cause when this process from
ingenuity to regeneration happens and in
the mouse on the road and modeling we
know that what happens in in the first
days we have the breakout of mild
breakdown of myelin which followed but
Schwann cell proliferation roughly in
the first week this is happening you
have observed the generation from day 1
to day 3 or 5 when our recovery happens
in four weeks
a month later and one very early event
in the first day is this induction of
schedule so we now where we come is that
we were interested from the beginning in
this window which is from the injury to
day one so this 24 hours we think are
very crucial and why we think that
because this is 20 this 24 hours will
dictate the quality and the of the
signals and the transcriptional
regulator inscriptional regulation that
will act activate or downregulated genes
which are very important for
continuation of this program and we know
that in these 24 hours we have major to
down regulation and the c-jun
but how does this happen yes we have
signaling we have intracellular
signaling but we don't know how this is
regulated we don't know exactly what
that the mechanism angulate this
transcription factor the either the
transcription of them and even their
function so here is where we established
our hypothesis and our program is that
we wanted to see in this very very
transient period like one day between
hours to one day after the injury is is
there an epigenetic mechanism egg you
laid the transcription of these
transcription factors and this
regulation in our reviews should be
dynamic because these transcription
factors can they have to be able to go
up and down the leather so transcription
factors so why we focus on anti sense
transcription I mean like a brief very
very full review is that yes we know
that human genome is prescribed by
directional manner even though people
thought for many many years that most of
them they are de subscription in is like
basically junk DNA in the form of
Addison's RNA so these are the we know
now that this 70% of human genes are
transcribed in both orientations and
obviously this is not junk it has a
significant role so the characteristics
of Addison's RNA transcription is we
know now that it exists as in the form
of short like micro RNAs or lung
conditions RNAs and a global transcript
or analysis that has been done so that
70% of the mammalian transcriptome
contains natural sense and distance
pairs the Addison's are Anitra's means
that the formation of heterochromatin
repressive complexes on contre motives
and with the Addison's transcript you
can target multiple genes like micro
RNAs which is very well known or
specific genes which is usually the
longan sense are in a way of function
it's a fast and very reversibly
regulation so it's very dynamic and the
important thing is that the artists and
scientists can regulate the translation
which is how we know how we started
I mean everybody's using srna's now
microRNAs this kind of reagents which
regulate eventually translation of
proteins but you can also regulate
transcription with addition studies the
models that were publishing years ago
like eleven years ago is that that
addison's transcription can happen
either head to head from like a scooter
stopping from five event but this
transcript medicine stressing this is
the sense transcript or that tail to
tail so this is the five event starting
from the sense and their distance is
here so so the transfer is actually
complemented at the free end or
overlapping within the sequence and
again many many years ago like eleven
years ago people put together for
hypothesis of Tsavo
Addison's prescription main work the
first hypothesis which is turned out not
to be the case is that it could be that
RNA polymerase ii RNA polymerase is
actually collide on an adsense analysis
orientation and stopped transcription
then they there was a papers described
that maybe add editions transcripts must
RNA splicing sites and that changes how
the transcripts are transcribed also
there is a possibility that interfere
with RNA editing and by having the other
substructure still being useful inhibit
RNA editing which leads to nuclear
attentions of the transcripts or
degradation but they're the model that
actually prevailed and it is studied
widely now is chromatin remodeling and
chromatin remodeling is the model where
the addison's RNA either recruits
recruits epigenetic
modifying complexes with histones and
histone modifying enzymes or it's part
of complexes on the promoter to regulate
genes so coming to our work is we
studied both we started with studying
the lone role of micro RNAs in nerve
injury response some years ago and we
have published this data is basically
just an overview of this
and because this is actually the same
way to the latest work that we're doing
is that after the nerve injury we
perform a micro RNA array and we found
lots of microRNAs in this you see it in
this table it's six hours stuff their
injury and 24 hours of their injury that
are deregulate so most interestingly if
you take this bathe big players like
shocks to easier to see june nanak ID to
which further major role in a nerve
injury response they have multiple
binding sites for this micro rna's that
we found that the deregulated so each
transcript has multiple sites so this
actually made us put together and and
proposed this hypothesis that the you
cannot really say that one micro RNA
regulates a transcript it's a
combinatorial interaction of micro rna's
we think transcripts in order to
understand how to make how this
mechanism works and not only it's a
combinatorial direction something which
is very difficult to interpret but it's
extremely important is the the secondary
structure of the micro Dennis and the
RNA that the transcript the target plays
a major also basically what is the
accessibility of these targets so how
much energy you need in order to the
micro RNA to bind to the transcript
actually dictates which micro RNA is
more important for the regulation of
this transcript so we did this analysis
to all these major players and we found
that the element of the promoter of
easier to which is called Mayan specific
element has this very high affinity
binding sites for micro RNA 7:09 and
this created this this the question that
is it possible that micro RNA 709 binds
to the man who through the MSE of major
to promoter and regulates the
transcription of it here too so we need
list the studies and we showed that yes
after injury the level of easier to is
is basically as a protein for a doubt is
completely gone and as it transcript you
sit down regulated but if you
overexpress this micro RNA
my karate may mimic what do you see and
this is a new PR unknown that's the
nascent prescription of igf2 is is
inhibited and then we prove that the
disinhibition is actually orchestrated
by the micro RNA 709 which brings a
surrogate to methylated k-27 of the
promoter as a as a complex and this
complex formation B actually depends for
the presence of the micro RNA 709
because if you treat it with RNA stage
and and break their RNA DNA bones then
you don't have the formation of the
complex so basically we we showed with
with this work will show that the
defendant wins early induces
deregulation of micro RNAs in sciatic
nerves and the description factor
expression is regulated by a synergistic
action of micro rna's and specifically
micro 709 media is the formation of
epigenetic complexes on a specific the
main specific element of the AG of the
promoter so now turn to the most recent
work and the recent publication is that
what is the role of the of long
non-coding RNAs in nerve injury response
so in order to answer this question we
we perform a modified fibrates protocol
focusing on the promoter of EGR - since
we already had the data that there is a
micro RNA regulation of digital recorder
so then we did this five range protocol
and the primer working and identified a
1,000 nucleotides sequence upstream of
this particular start site of easier -
so which we sequence we cloned it and
then we did all the computational
analysis searching databases to see if
this is a non-coding RNA that has been
reported before and it was not so we
decided that if this is really true it's
it's a novel madison's RNA so then we we
check them publish that database RNA
seek data basis and this is actually
from from a paper published from favori
lab is that they have done RNA seek on
mouse
sciatic nerves and we downloaded this
throw bait out they are amazing which
are available for everybody so then we
search for the if the micro RNA is
expressed in this data and we found that
yes it is as it's supposed to be in the
chromosome 10 and this is the if there
is a 450 nucleotides which is actually
considered the mature Addison's an a on
the complementary to the promoter of
easier to and these are three different
repetitions from different animal so
we're very confident completely by these
are not they are data but it's very nice
to see that this exists in RNA
sequencing of other people so this
increased our confidence that the data
are real but we wanted to see if this
Addison's RNA is we can actually
visualize it in mouse sciatic nerves so
we performed a fist experiment and what
you see here is is with red dots rs.100
which is a very widely expressed market
of Schwann cells and the green dots are
actually they are distance RNA so this
is in situ hybridization so as you see
it's the expression is low as it is as
it's it's expected for a distance rnase
but it is specific on on s 100
expressing cells and you can see it in
the cytoplasm you can see it in the
nucleus as well and these are the
positive and negative controls so now
the next question that we ask is there a
regulation for this micro RNA is this
does this have at all so we develop them
as strand-specific PCR so basically with
the strand specific speed PCR using
different primers you cannot amplify
either the cell strand which in our case
is the EGF to mRNA or the addition
strand which again in our case is the
longer distance RNA so we performed
nerve injury isolated the the distal
part of the sciatic nerve and we perform
this
strand-specific qpcr and we showed that
this time called 6 12 and 24 hours of
that injury you have especially four six
and 12 hours you have a very highly
significant up regulation of the
expression of the Addison Saturday and
at the same time interval you have an
inhibition of expression of the EGF to
Emily so this is correlates very nicely
so actually if you do it for a less the
pista kulfi relation it's like really
highly correlated so then we perform
this serial and the Lucian analysis from
using a protocol that was published and
to identify what is the abundance of the
alert to identify the absolute abundance
of the Addison's RNA in the sciatic
nerve and we found that after injury
especially the 12 hours where you see 6
and 12 hours will you see that it's so
pretty
you have close to 4,000 as an average
500 picograms per hundred nano grams of
RNA so it's a low expression and again
the literature agrees with that that the
artists and scientists are really low in
expression and if you want to compare is
somehow like 40 times less than the
expression of the idea to mRNA okay but
now the question is does it have
biological function yes it's expressed
yes it's up regulated but does it have a
biological function so in order to
address this question we develop
lentivirus that expresses this antisense
RNA and when you do perform ectopic
expression of this understands RNA you
see that we inhibit the idea of to mRNA
Express you sit here not only the mRNA
but also the protein expression of each
year too so it seems just by vice
influences in purified strands cells it
definitely does something and when it
does it inhibits the transcription and
translation of easier to transcription
factor so then we wanted to see if they
as a role in myelination so here you see
this drg swanson koat cultures in in red
you see the myelin
that is formed in a control culture
infected with a lentivirus with like a
non-target england lentivirus
while when you infect these sculptures
with a limb diverse expressing their
distance you have tremendous denying
Asia and you see it in higher
magnification here where the myelin you
have like bits and pieces of the myelin
so it really affects myelination and we
in order to actually improve them the
specificity and so the specificity of
this we develop this oligonucleotide gap
myrrh which is basically an on the
nucleotide complementary to the
Addison's RNA and if you overexpress
this it blocks the other sensory so we
wanted to rescue the demyelination by
incubating the disc answers with
Addison's government and we actually did
so when you culture the cells with a
scrambled gum well which thought doesn't
forget anything you don't rescue the
demyelination but when you culture them
with a gap man that blocks the
expression of the Addison's RNA then you
rescue the myelination and you see the
quantification here so this is highly
specific and it depends on the
expression of the idea to him a name so
that was that was very encouraging so
but then what we did in order to
increase our confidence with all this
data is we formed like five difference
in the nucleotide gap nuts and we show
that if you overexpress
the if you if you give this gap nurse if
you overexpress this covers what happens
they block the expression of the essence
RNA and the increased expression of the
easier to mRNA
so the old work as is supposed to so we
wanted to to be able to give to deliver
this gap less in vivo in order to study
individual response so we started a
collaboration with both language lab at
MIT where he developed for us his post
was developed for us a biodegradable
hydrogel which actually it has
incorporated this algorithm low-tide gap
mess within the hydrogen so basically
how this works when you do an injury we
do the you open up and do the selling
and i've been
then you you actually load the hydrogen
which is it is in liquid form which has
the gap mat inside you load it on top of
the side you can even keep this won't
open for two minutes
and within two minutes because if the
the hydrogel becomes a gel and and then
you close and then this starts to
degrade and it's biodegradable hydrogel
it's a non swelling hydrogel and as it
degrades it releases the governor so we
have done in vitro kinetics with this
and we know that it releases government
for seven days that was perfect because
we wanted to study that this this you
know initial period of nerve injury
response so we use this solubility
o-type the hydrogen with the gap mass to
perform nerve injury and here is an
electron microscopy study where you have
in two days five days and seven days of
their injury mice that didn't get
anything
mais not were treated with a scrambled
up marisa control and mouse that were
treated with the audicence RNA governor
the most important is this
quantification myelinated the myelinated
number of myelinated axons but what the
most important thing that i wanted to
focus here is that even we're talking
about one week after and the nerve
injury where 30 here is not a
compression injury is a complete
transection of the sciatic nerve so
basically you cut the nerve completely
so here you have seven days one week
after complete cut of the setting there
and you see the control and you see the
Scramble there is no mind is completely
gradation
but in the treated now you still have
then actions which are completely minded
of course you have loss of myelin air
obviously this is a cut nerve but the
fact that you can see actions with
complete myelination still and we cast
and computers actually it's just
astonishing it just mean he being the
analysis RNA you can do that so this is
really really important so of course
then
this creates a lot of questions how does
this work and the first thing that we
wanted to prove was that this really
affects transcription of eager to
because we haven't proved it and in
order to do this we did this nuclear
amnon experiment when we showed that
expression of the absence RNA inhibits
nation transcription of video - so it
really targets to India to transcription
and also in order to connect with our
with this data to say that really we
have the the the cytochrome retains the
major structural myelin proteins we did
a fan course of Western blood after the
addition of the Addison's kepner's of
the scrambling governors and you see
even seven days that both and my protein
zero and TMP 22 the structural proteins
of peripheral myelin are really a pretty
liberal state actually in order to say
it correctly they are still not
inhibited when you straight with the the
gap and you block the episode and
Saturday so this is real and this this
inhibition of the a distance can have
the ability to actually delay the
myelination of the injury so go to to
the mechanism and understand how this
works
so the papers that have been published
the recent years that open to signal it
it is known also that after injury the
new Reglan axis is disturbed disturbed
of course and this effects everyone to
signaling within the strand cells so the
airplane to regulates expression of vgf
to and in order to I mean other people I
mean jobs variants lab have shown this
Patricia cuz I guess paper and they have
shown this that when you inhibit
airplane to land with you inhibited with
the Euro 126 inhibitor what happens you
inhibit EGF two expressions so this
direct link between Elkin two signals
you have to expression influencers so
what we wanted to see if we treat this
with the - one cells with UO 126 and
blocker
- what is the effect of the idea of tool
Addison Saturday and what we found is
that when you block easier - sorry
everyone to signal link yes then this is
a queue PC update the AJR to mRNA is
inhibited as it was shown by others and
it's significantly inhibited by the
expression of the audicence RNA is
actually activated then it's
significantly activated so it seems that
everyone - signaling has in the normal
Schwann cell has a role to keep them the
audicence RNA in any press state when
you inhibit aircon - signalling then you
have the repression of the expression of
the audicence RNA an inhibition of the
EGF - mRNA expression so how does this
work so in order to understand this we
thought again based on the work of John
Vernon and Patricia Kaas a guest of the
nature in your sense paper that they
have they connected the expression of
easier to anyone to signal into yy1 so
we thought that we will study the same
the role of white way one of this
regulation based on shown another aspect
and this aspect is that if you really
look closely at the sequence of the
Edison's RNAi upstream of the
transcription start site so you see that
very close to the to the start of the
artisans RNA sequence there is this
motif which is the yy1 binding motif and
the interesting thing for this motif
it's actually whywe yy1 binding in both
direction both the sense in the
anticipation in this little part of the
sequence which is close to a hundred
nucleotides has all the elements of a
bi-directional promoter so we thought
that maybe this part of the antisense
RNA has a role which is part of the
easier to promoter as actually a role of
the bi-directional promoted for the
audicence RNA as well so we focused on
on what and the only transcription
factor binding site and this part of the
Addison's RNA is the
this way one bi-directional so we
focused on this side which we called as
one side and we also focused on a
different side not focus will used as a
positive control is with this way and s2
side which is fine we're upstream and it
has been shown in the literature that
it's a real bona fide y11 binding site
and this is just to confirm that we're
doing that I think so we perform a DNA
chip for yy1 with and without the
addition of the U of the new 126 to
inhibit that 1/2 and this is a Wi-Fi one
chip on Bajor to promote a DNA so we saw
that yes when you inhibit and want to
signaling you have partial inhibition of
where a1 binding to the s2 region to the
estimative which is a positive control
which is looks at so that the technique
is working and there is no binding
either with the control or they happen
to in this one on the DNA which is fine
it actually agrees with the literature
this but when you do an RNA ID to see if
y1 interrupts with the other sensor
delay okay what's very interesting is
that in control Schwann cells it has
almost no interaction with with the
irony but when you inhibit up on to Y y1
is significantly increases binding to
this one side and the edge to side but
the mostly to the s-1 side so it seems
that inhibition of el punto signaling
induces binding of y y1 to the Addison
Saturday on this specific wire you are
in binding motif so which is great so
what is what what is there and how does
this happen
so why do you need to it to it to
inhibit that happen to signal what
what's going on so if you look at the Y
y1 in general the regulation of going
one depends on post translational
modifications and they have people have
shown that Y y1 can be phosphorylated it
can be a satellite it can be bigger than
related so we were we focused on
phosphorylation since you know it's
it's a result of of kindness it could be
a result of interstellar kindness so
what we did is we constructed several
program mutants on several settings that
yy1 has so basically we mutated from
setting to alanine so they're not they
cannot be phosphorylated the one one
eight serene the 184 the 247 and then we
did double mutant one one eight and 184
and we performed yy1 RNAi eyepiece both
with the Wi-Fi non-mutated yy1 and each
of these mutants
so what we found is that when we you you
actually delete seven one one eight you
inhibit binding of one by one to them
Addison's RNA but the most interesting
part is when you inhibit when you delete
setting 184 so it cannot be
phosphorylated there then you have a
huge increase on the binding of one to
them Addison Saturday and the
combinatorial there's a combination of
this this double mutant where you delete
both one one eight and 184 it's still up
regulated compared to the control which
to us means that the 184 is the dominant
regulatory side which potentially if
it's difference or elated it actually
increases the expression of white one
sorry the binding of why I went to the
other sense RNA so this data actually
are summarized here where we proposed
this white boy on forceful sweets as the
regulatory aspect further for the
control of the other sense RNA
expression so basically what we think is
happening is that in a non injured
Schwann cell everything works fine and
you have the new regulating to a b2 and
b3 receptors at the being f12 then you
have phosphorylation of yy1
which represses the Addison's RNA and
activates the expression video to Emily
but when injury happens you know this
one to the very initial
step is that they open to you have a
very transient block of Bel Canto
signaling which brought probably the the
hypothesis that activates a protein
phosphatase that actually phosphorylates
we're going one specifically I'm setting
184 and the difference for related yy1
binds the Addison's RNA with high
affinity activates the expression of
Addison's RNA and at the same time
inhibits the expression easier to mRNA
so this is the model that we proposed
so to summarize own the data both for
the micro RNA and the longer distance
RNA we presented an like data for to to
actually establish an antisense RNA code
if you ain't doing p NS injury response
so what do we think is happening is
during differentiation you have
expression of gentle oxygen substitute d
d NF that sonic hedgehog which are
actually should be inhibited and the
mRNAs involved in this inhibition from
from papers that have been published and
from our own work is listed here and the
age of two Addison's RNA is also
involved then during injury you have the
concerted action of both micro rnas and
the addition Saturday to regulate the
transition from a differentiated to d
differentiated stay and this is a
dynamic regulation the major players is
the her2 gene and the sigil and we have
preliminary data to show the relation of
c-jun eyes as well for Addison's RNA and
we know that the micro RNAs that are
involved we proved it is 709 140 from
the work of judgment granted lots of
love as well and now we also know that
the age of Addison's RNA is involved in
this dynamic regulation so currently
what we're standing and we have some
very interesting data is that we're
trying to do a social proteomic analysis
of yy1 to identify other possible sites
that are phosphorylated or differs for
related during nerve injury and how does
it
do these for society regulate binding to
the back to the Addison ceranae where
we're trying to do phosphor why why one
had an AI piece which first of all we
have to develop good antibodies for that
and this is what we're trying to do so
we are already started the genome-wide
h3k27 and h3k4 trimethylation sequencing
after inhibition of major to understand
Saturday to see if you have a transition
between repressive and activated
complexes specific promoters that this
complexes erection orchestrated by the
Addison's RNA we are also started an and
we are already developed this chip
method which basically what you form you
know tandem only goes that actually
cover the whole area of of the Addison's
RNA and these are by accumulated if you
use them as a bait to break the
Addison's RNA to precipitate the other
sense RNA together with the proteins or
DNA that is by a screwed up so we're
actually doing this in order to identify
globally what are the interactors both
are so protein and acid DNA that these
understands are in a interacts and i
want to say that we're doing this
because we think that there is a other
sense RNA acts obviously in cease to
regulate the age of two but there is a
very high it is very likely that it can
work in trance as well and and it has
been proved for other adolescents RNA
like for the x-chromosome inactivation
that you can have
Addison's RNA that work across
chromosomes and we want to see if that
this is inserted a that we identified
can do the same and this will actually
lead to make it to two interventions
that is where we can actually inhibit
specific chromatic modified enzymes to
see how the if this regulates response
after injury and we also want to do some
behavioral studies to see if we modulate
the expression of the audicence RNA and
we modulate this chromatin modifying
enzymes do we have do we
since pain responses do we change the
myelination do we change that the degree
of the militia or degree of regeneration
this will be very interesting to
actually prove if our studies for the
Edison sorry may have could have a
translation flavor
and I will stop here I want to
acknowledge the people in my lab mostly
my post good past postdoc my god who is
the fastest of the last paper that we
published who has done most of the work
for there longer distance RNA the other
people in the lab as well and
collaborators and the funding agencies
as well so if you can unshare the
presentation a couple of questions yes
these are like real basic early things
one is the like you showed all these
phosphorylation and dephosphorylation of
yyy site and do you know like what is
the signal goes there like how does
these pace know what to do and what is
the signal like as soon as the
denervation happens the goes there and a
you need to phosphorylate our
dephosphorylation 'el which is sent out
from the injury site yes so we think
that the M is early signal so we have
some preliminary evidence for that so we
think that the early signal is not is
not actually you know I signal that in
terms of how you think that is a
receptor ligand interaction actually is
the opposite it's is this fact so it
sends a signal through what we have so
far through the new regulator B 2 and B
3 axis the recent axis is despaired ok
because the action is the first probably
the first element of a sidedness to
signal that something wrong is happening
yeah so the disruption of over quanto
sorry of the new regulator buffet
interaction is the first thing the first
signaling event that we have no no
that is happening in Swanson though very
early to give you an example very when
I'm saying very at least four hours of
their injury in vivo so we did the
injury and four hours we taken the
nerves you have a deregulation of of new
regular want to signal already and you
already have activation of the Addison's
RNA and you already have activation of
specific phosphatases in the Schwann
cells so that's not a complete answer to
your question because there could be
other receptors of course that can be
directly regulated after injury but we
haven't done and we don't know
necessarily what other is what other in
the receptor Olin Lagon interaction is
disturbed okay and other thing is that
you had mentioned like there is a
complete when you do the experiment it
is the complete denervation right like
you just chop off the nerves yes and
like you showed with the hydrogel
hydrogels that there is still like
connection built up when you do the add
those hydrogel with all egos or anti
sense or whatever you have used so is
this can be like you see similar thing
in the spinal cord injury like there is
a breakdown of spinal call like so can
you like see the similar mechanism like
it is just like hypothetical question
it's very difficult to say for this
panel so we obviously at some point
during VCS doing this work we we wanted
to see if they easier to is expressed in
one good undersides okay it's not so may
be the same kind of mechanism works but
it's not the same same physicians RNA
yeah now what is interesting is that
there is there is work that is being
done that using scaffolds or hydrogens
british between the you know that the
cap the danger sites in the spinal cord
and it's um you know encouraging the
results there that it helps regeneration
myelination ordered establish some new
connections but i think that this is a
very tough question to answer and the
addison suddenly the role of addison
Saturdays in Norwood and recite
myelination or the remyelination yes
it's something that needs to be done
okay yeah that's it I think it's an
excellent talk and I learned a lot about
it about your work and it will be on our
website as soon as we are done with that
like you can now you'll send your link
and is it okay is it okay if I share
your email address to all the Facebook
Linkedin like if at all they are
interested in your work they can contact
you yeah yeah yeah okay so I'll do that
so if at all anybody is interested
collaborate or looking for a position or
anything they can get back to you and
you can go from there
again thank you very much I really
appreciate you doing this and hope to
see more of your work in the near future
thank you so much thank you thank you